rappelez-vous mars 2020 l'épidémie de
kobe de 19 s'abat sur l'hexagone branle
bas de combat salutaire confinement et
surtout pénurie de masques la france
réalise alors qu'elle est dépendante de
la chine et décide donc de relancer le
masque bleu blanc rouge il nous faut
aussi produire davantage en france sur
notre sol pour réduire notre dépendance
et donc nous équiper dans la durée je
veux que d'ici la fin de l'année nous
ayons obtenu justement cette
indépendance pleine et entière du coup
les usines ont tourné à plein régime au
premier trimestre 2001 21 la france
produisait 100 millions de masques par
semaine soit presque trente fois plus
qu'en janvier de l'année précédente le
secteur compte désormais une trentaine
d'entreprises dans le pays contre 4
avant la crise sauf que cette embellie
elle n'aura pas duré longtemps
la chine a baissé ses prix après l'été
2020 et a commencé à subventionner ses
exportations de masques à compter
d'avril 2021 aujourd'hui un masque
chinois vendus en france est bien moins
cher qu'en 2019 alors que les matières
premières ont augmenté de 30% et le fret
transport a été multipliée par cinq un
masque chinois coûte de 2 à 4 centimes
d'euro contre 6 à des centimes pour son
équivalent français alors comme ça les
cars ne paraît pas énorme mais vu les
volumes commandés en 2020 on atteint des
milliards d'euros de surcoûts logique
que les acheteurs soient tentés plus de
95 % des appels d'offres publics ont été
affectés à des importateurs de masques
chinois depuis l'été 2020 résultat les
fabricants français sont à la peine la
filière tournerait à la moitié voire à
15 % de sa capacité seulement du coup au
gouvernement on s'indigne je trouve ça
très choquant aujourd'hui c'est aux
hôpitaux de commander des masques aux
régions aux départements l'état a pris
ses responsabilités nous avons passé une
commande d'un milliard de masques en de
l'année dernière alors oui un milliard
de masques c'est bien mais ça ne pèse
pas énormément face aux 30 2 milliards
d'unités importer la même année et puis
le stock stratégique et reconstituer
maintenant l'état ne passera plus ce
genre de commandes et puis si l'on en
croit le magazine alternatives
économiques
administrations françaises n'auraient
poussé concrètement à l'achat de masques
français que du bout des doigts histoire
de ne pas trop alourdir les dépenses
publiques l'éternel schizophrénie
française qu'on retrouve aussi derrière
la tva sur les masques au ministère de
l'industrie on veut la maintenir à 5 5%
mais aux finances on aimerait bien la
remontée à 20% après le 31 décembre au
risque de plomber encore plus la
compétitivité du masque hexagonal et
tant pis si dix mille emplois sont
désormais menacés tout comme d'ailleurs
la fameuse indépendance prônée par
emmanuel macron il y à 18 mois pourtant
le masque français c'était l'image même
du monde d'après allez on termine par du
bruno le maire la france sait relever de
cette crise économique grâce aux
entrepreneurs et aux entrepreneuse de
france grâce à leur ténacité grâce à
leur courage grâce à leur embauche grâce
à leur inventivité
vous avez été
exceptionnel dans cette crise alors vive
et l'entrepreneur vie d'entrepreneur de
france et vive la france tout court le
ministre ne le sait peut-être pas mais
pour un fabricant de masques français
c'est loges c'est un éloge funèbre